merci la parole à présent Monsieur
Philippe Dalier merci monsieur le
Président
Bizet nous nous réjouissons de
l'engagement réaliste et responsable du
Parlement européen et en particulier de
nos collègues du PPE dans une
négociation budgétaire qui a été
difficile qui peut paraître complexe
mais qui conforte la démocratie
européenne dans l'esprit du traité de
Lisbonne je ne reviendrai pas sur le
niveau du budget en baisse alors certes
moins que cela avait été craint mais
c'est bien le résultat de la crise
économique que traverse la plupart des
pays il faut bien l'accepter mais cela
ne doit pas nous faire douter de
l'avenir et plus que jamais nous devons
afficher nos convictions européennes
notre ambition politique pour l'Europe
et maintenir l'objectif d'un budget plus
élevé à terme lorsque cela sera possible
mais peut-être et surtout d'un budget
plus efficace cependant je m'interroge
quand le gouvernement évoque de manière
assez incantatoire le retour à la
croissance car je ne comprends pas bien
qu'elles en sont les conséquences en
matière budgétaire et pour cause le
gouvernement l'avocat d'une politique de
stimulation de la dépense au niveau
européen
défendent-ils des programmes qui
conforteraient la croissance potentielle
soutient-il des projets transfrontaliers
à forte plus-value il me semble qu'il
serait nécessaire de s'entendre avec nos
partenaires européens sur ces questions
préalables à toute utilisation des
financements européens par ailleurs dans
la négociation en cours sur le budget le
partent le Parlement européen a mis sur
la table des propositions concrètes et
courageuses je souhaiterais connaître la
position du gouvernement au regard de
ses propositions etes-vous prêt monsieur
le ministre a accepté une clause de
revoyure qui est une manière d'adapter
le budget européen à l'évolution de la
situation économique êtes-vous prêt à
accepter plus de flexibilité ou de
fongibilité on en a parlé dans la
gestion des crédits enfin êtes-vous prêt
à garantir une gestion rigoureuse grâce
par exemple à une révision générale des
politiques publiques adaptées au niveau
européen très bien monsieur le ministre
ce sénateur moi aussi je me réjouis que
nous ayons adopté un budget à 960
milliards d'euros sur la période 2014
bien plus élevé même si vous estimez que
c'est insuffisant à l'accord qui avait
été passé par le Président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy qui était
d'accord pour un budget à 860 milliards
nous avons adopté un budget de 960
milliards c'est-à-dire 100 milliards de
plus de ce qui était prévu par la
majorité précédente il me semble que
c'est une précision que je devais vous
dire vous dites ensuite est-ce qu'il y a
des incantations en quelque sorte sur
une politique de relance de dépenses
très précisément je vais vous dire ça se
traduit comment par le fait que nous
avons en juin 2012 à l'occasion du
premier sommet européen avec le
président de la République François
Hollande acté un pacte de relance qui va
se traduire par le fait que la Banque
européenne d'investissement a été
recapitalisée de 10 milliards d'euros
avec ces 10 milliards d'euros de
recapitalisation la Banque européenne
d'investissement va pouvoir prêter aux
différents états 60 milliards de prêts
sur 2013 2014-2015 la part de la France
sur ses 60 milliards c'est 21 milliards
je vous le dis aussi élu de la
République pour tous les projets
d'accompagnement sur vos territoires 7
milliards cette année 7 milliards l'an
prochain 7 milliards d'années d'après
pour les collectivités locales et nous
avons demandé à l'abbaye qu'elle prête
aussi au petit et moyennes entreprises
qui ne trouvent plus les fonds
disponibles dans les banques classiques
c'est aussi la création du Lean de 6
milliards d'euros au bénéfice de
l'accompagnement des politiques à
destination de la jeunesse j'ai déjà
répondu sur cette question tout à
l'heure et que nous allons essayer de
concentrer sur l'année 2014 et l'année
2015 quant au grands travaux
d'interconnexion ils vont bénéficier
d'une augmentation budgétaire de 140%
après un arbitrage qui entraînait tout
le monde et ses grands travaux c'est
quoi c'est par exemple le canal senor
c'est par exemple à grande liaison
ferroviaire entre la France et l'Italie
parce que derrière ces grands travaux il
y a de l'emploi non réalisable dont nous
avons besoin pour créer des emplois pour
l'économie française et pour une relance
à l'échelle de l'Europe merci Monsieur
Dallier pour une réaction rapide
les élections européennes approchent
l'an prochain et je crois ici que sur
tous les bancs nous sommes inquiets du
résultat qui pourrait sortir des urnes
et pas seulement en France dans tous les
pays européens on le voit bien le
sentiment anti-européen progresse et de
manière très inquiétante je pense qu'il
faut que nous nous interrogions sur le
pourquoi de cette affaire je pense qu'il
faut que nous fassions preuve de
pédagogie et de responsabilité de
pédagogie pour que nos compatriotes
comprennent mieux ce à quoi sert
l'Europe qu'ils comprennent
effectivement qu'elle les a beaucoup
protégés dans la crise de 2008-2009
comprend aussi ce que vous faites du
budget ce que nous faisons du budget
européen il faut aussi que
l'administration de Bruxelles comme l'a
rappelé Jean Arthuis accepte de faire
des économies parce que vous avez lu la
presse il y a beaucoup de commentaires
très négatifs et beaucoup de nos
concitoyens effectivement trouvent que
il doit être fait des efforts également
à ce niveau là mes chers collègues c'est
ce que je souhaite pour que le sentiment
européen puisse continuer à progresser
de nouveau merci